all right we are now live for another
live reading from my book uh reason
fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
and we are picking up at page 215
in the middle of maurice blondel's
presentation and the conversation that
goes on
about that
uh from the etude associative
philosophic so this was published in
these etude philosophies
titled the problem
of catholic philosophy
and the last part of this we've spent
three three of these sessions
reading through
this
longest part of the book the longest
thing that i translated we had maurice
blondel's presentation itself
and then we had some letters that were
sent reason they they were doing letters
is blondel was nearly blind at the time
and did a lot of his work through
correspondence and
having a secretary read things aloud to
him and then taking dictation
and then finally there was a
recorded discussion
between maurice blondell jacques
polliard and gaston bergie people who
are interested in all of these questions
and issues people also who are also part
of the society they detude phyllis
sophie
and who would regularly go to the
meetings so
we're going to begin here
discussion between maurice blondel
jacques polliard and gaston berger mr
jacques polyard
how should we consider this interior
demand for god whose character of
universality were concerned to set in
full light and which would already be
the catholic fact must we see in it a
psychological fact but as much as the
desire for god is incontestable for one
who intimately makes an experiment of it
just as much it will appear contestable
to others to inductively conclude that
such a desire
is universally the ground of human
nature
must we instead regard that fact as a
historical fact observed from the
outside
but then do all civilizations all
religious traditions manifest it with
the same evidence
to look there where this demand for god
presents itself with the preciseness you
attribute to it that is to look at it
from the side of christian tradition
this would be to provide ourselves with
what instead needs to be established
it seems to me that observation no more
the historians and the psychologists
cannot be sufficient to apprehend the
universality of this need you judge to
be basic
from that point on let it be a matter
not simply of a fact to note but of an
essence
to determine
mr maurice blondel i thank you for
teaming in my view and the surplus of
precision that you demand i have not
claimed that experience under any of its
psychological historical moral or even
mystical forms suffices to provide a
clear and distinct idea of our divine
appetite even less of our supernatural
vocation
and in a sense if we stick with notions
formulated in the spontaneous
consciousness of the majority of people
it seems that god would be the absent
the
misrecognized the refused the excluded
the denied one par excellence
still against that appearance we have to
make two implicit attitudes converge on
the one hand if there are idolaters
iconoclasts anti-theists there are
actually no atheists for nobody ceases
living for what is not given and not
finite surpassing by thought and desire
what is submitted to striving towards an
ideal and consequently as st thomas
noted awaiting or even already
understanding the approach of an unknown
of a good of a guest
before knowing that this desired visitor
is happiness in god
on the other hand reflections normal
role is precisely to make us recognize
through all the illusions and failures
the entirely close presence and the
desired and solely solitary role of him
who
even anonymous can calm the restlessness
or orient it towards the end point that
can give it peace
empirical data remain obscure and
equivocal
a metaphysical interpretation if it be
very inclusive and completely concrete
is thus indispensable so that man raises
himself per gradus debitos to what is
his thoughts proper object and his
destiny's normal end
thus even faced with revealed and lived
christianity a work of the soul and of
reason remains indispensable and as you
say
there is in fact quote an essence to
determine
whether at first to make the essential
nature of reasonable being precise or
whether to measure its aspiration scope
and by means of nature and its
deficiencies to define the exact notion
and what has been called the
supernatural's desirability
jacques polliard
it seems then that this natural appetite
for god would cling to a demand for
surpassing that is not only a fact to
observe but a law or a form inherent to
the structure of human thought
and i understand then that coming back
to observation one would illuminate by
this essential demand's light
in the at first disconcerting diversity
of human aptitudes anticipations or the
haltings the
deviations or the negations that always
suppose the same fundamental law
definitively absolute religious
indifference does not exist
blondel you know rightly that what most
preoccupies the philosopher are the
specific characters of this natural
appetite for god for even after one has
had to admit this perpetual surpassing
about which pascal said that it proved
man's vocation towards the infinite
an ambiguity and infidelity towards that
call
must be denounced and avoided without a
doubt the varieties of religious
experience and of its interpretation
are indefinite and all can serve in good
faith as vehicles for the saving faith
and for the participation in the
invisible and supernatural soul of the
church
but this catholicity of intention does
not in any way make it so that these
different forms would be objectively
equivalent the most inadequate just as
the highest have value only by secretly
participating in a precise and
subsisting truth as well as in a
spiritual disposition that reflections
role is precisely to unfailingly discern
but if there is a catholic philosophy it
is the one that explains the conditions
and the complete demands of what as a
philosopher saint bonaventure called the
intellect's itinerary
taking note
of this law of man's perpetual
surpassing of himself by himself is not
sufficient it is a matter of not missing
something here not imagining that one
pulls out of oneself the urine for
transcendence
rather one will be missing oneself from
the moment on when one would claim to
draw this transcendence from our very
imminence or to make it come down here
and to hold it by our own powers and our
human reason you are quite right
therefore to insist on the difficulty of
discovering the true and pure solution
above the counterfeits and the
weaknesses of the religious aspiration
if it is pos this is pollyard if
this show the natural desire for god is
itself powerless to attain its object it
is quite understandable then that the
desire for a divine aid
would not be itself of the natural order
but already something supernatural a
grace
only will not this catholic philosophy's
most difficult task be showing that
actually the empty space cannot be
humanly filled
certainly
it is not philosophy that we'll be able
to conquer the good our soul desires if
we understand by philosophy a work of
organization of concepts that would aim
at a closed system
systematization satisfied with itself
but for certain philosophers
is philosophy not something different
is it not for them a matter of coming to
live
a life of the intellect that would truly
be a life to strive by concentration of
intellectual power towards a form of
knowledge superior to discursive
movements and to organization of
concepts in the end to produce in
oneself by the very path of
philosophical meditation and intuition
metaphysical and mystical at the same
time in mystical because metaphysical no
longer a rational systematization that
would be a religious and complacent in
itself by its forgetting of the
fundamental restlessness
but a noetic
meditative contemplation
that far from rejecting or ignoring
religion would make us say to a person
who practices religion that it is
philosophy itself that under the highest
form becomes religion
from that point of view which is not my
own human thought would itself surpass
itself but in this way of surpassing the
god of the philosopher would be a god
imminent to the thought of the
philosopher
can one show and how can one show that
there is a pseudo-mysticism here
blown down
your question touches more and more on
the problem's highest points and i
respond to and to respond to it we would
need here a longer examination i
undertake that elsewhere here i can
sketch a response
only by referring myself for example to
some of the recent works on saint john
of the cross and on spinoza
would we have to say that because there
is a super discursive thought a sort of
acquired unitary contemplation analogous
to mystical knowledge this high
speculation identifies philosophy and
religion by absorbing the human into the
divine itself a sublime pretension
but is it realized in spirit and in
truth in some other way than by a still
illusory and illegitimate extrapolation
is it not in formal contradiction with
the very principle of our thought that
sustains its consciousness and its life
only by distinguishing its own being
from the infinite object to which it
aspires without being able or wanting to
be absorbed there in pure
indetermination and infinity without
contours
would it be necessary that philosophy in
order to perfect itself must abolish
itself and that the supreme finished
state of knowledge would be the very
disappearance of thinking
and knowing if we do not want that if we
cannot even want this it is because
actually we can no longer think it and
affirm it without a fundamental illogic
and a metaphysical impossibility
the law and the secret wish of our
thought is to realize itself in the
universal and the eternal but without
losing itself there
the entire problem
is thus to constitute personal beings
and infinite being and from that point
on to accept our own limits at the same
time as accepting the divine gift that
alone puts back in in us the spirit of
adoption and the perfect life aspiring
which is our entire reason for being
these assertions are not at all
arbitrary simplistically juxtaposed they
are enfolded within each other
while remaining gratuitous on the side
of the common author of nature and grace
to speak of a saturating intuition and
of a philosophically mystical solution
is to mix together incompatible
assertions
it is to the prophet of expressions
lending themselves to everyone paying
oneself off with illusions and believing
oneself to have come to the perfect
endpoint of the life of the mind at the
precise moment when one kills in oneself
the religious and philosophical spirit
made from coherence humility and union
a union that is not in any way an
identification in an impersonal unity
but that to the contrary assumes the
multiplication of spiritual beings
finding their mutual and voluntary
society and in their common
participation in the divine charity the
consummation of these two charges
multiplicamini
if now i think about the domain that
this catholic philosophy can explore it
seems to me that beyond researchers
whose direction can be indicated by a
reversed form of saint augustine and
saint anselm's dictum fetum quadran's
intellectus
this philosophy must respond as well to
the authentic formula
fides quadrans intellectum
the first movement having been made
adherence to faith obtained is
philosophy that does not does philosophy
then not have to dip into dogma to
meditate on dogma in order to find it
new food for its appetite for
intelligibility
but then
do not the philosophers and the
theologians roles become quite difficult
to discern from each other
blondel
granted this is a tricky matter
unfolding the entire content of a
philosophy that does not confine itself
to a system of concepts but cooperates
with an entire organization of our
thoughts and our actions even when they
may be penetrated by super rational
stimulations that is quite evident in
itself
and still in another more true sense
confusion of the true orders nature and
grace must remain impossible to commit
from that point on when my previously
pointed out distinctions have been
established and admitted actually
what is really supernatural can never
insofar as such fall under the direct
grasp of consciousness nor be discerned
with certainty by reflection even for
speculative truths that seem to be
affirmed in common by reason and faith
it must be said that there remains a
formal
heterogeneity between what is known and
what is believed at the same time
whence the inviolable rule that saint
john of the cross outlines from which so
many spiritual men like father siren
deplored being separated to judge and
act even if one is engaged in
extraordinary paths by making use of all
the resources of good sense and of
science
so well that the doctor par excellence
of the supernatural in man had to say
that quote the true mystic is the most
reasonable of men
intellectus choir intellectum fidei and
intellectu simile
two inquiries that both of them actually
make recourse to an organizing reason
but that remain formally differentiated
according to our intellect's theological
employment and philosophical employment
the conclusions of both science even
when they seem to harmonize cannot be
confused that is why we must speak not
of absorption
of catholic philosophy by theology or
the christian contribution by rational
speculation but of a cooperation that
respects the specificity and the
heterogeneity of the method and the
object of both investigations
i ask that i'd be excused for a so
elliptical response to the immense
question
which we thank mr paliyard for having
raised in all of its statue
mr gaston
berger
if we seek to characterize catholic
philosophy in its results a difficulty
seems to present itself either the
demand that will end up in rationally
establishing the philosophical effort
will be precise the human soul has the
need for this kind of sacraments this
kind of dogmas but then what will faith
add
or
what the very essence of man and his
total experience rationally interpreted
demand is simply
a belief the admission of a radical
transcendence submission to some dogmas
and then faith's role remains in its
entirety but in this last case can one
speak of something other than a simply
quote religious philosophy
blondel
your question is perhaps the one most
important to bring to clarity for it
seems to lie beneath the majority of the
difficulties subsisting in minds
habituating to habituated to conceiving
philosophy as a partial discipline well
delimited and establishing itself in its
rational autonomy
actually even for those who recognize
some limits for philosophy despite its
pretension of being universal
the prevailing image is always that of a
rigid fence in front of an abyss our
reason cannot explore
but since we always have to make use of
metaphors
there is another image i use to describe
the reciprocal insertion of
philosophical thought and christian
thought just as two gases can penetrate
each other without combining or without
hindering each other so to speak as if
there were everywhere in them
interstices that allow their direct
cohabitation in the same area in the
same way the limits of philosophy are
everywhere in its most intimate fabric
in studying the genesis and the
ingredients of thought
i constantly find infinitesimal and real
fissures holes that require being filled
and that admit consequently the presence
or even the need of another reality
ahead of a heterogeneous and
complementary datum
from that point on the religious spirit
intervenes everywhere without intrusion
or confusion in the framework of
philosophical thought and i add that it
is no longer a matter of an extrinsic
line that would delimit an inscrutable
abyss it is a matter of gaps
of holes that offer determinable
contours and that by that very fact
could not receive an indeterminate
content
thus if in a general way
rational thought leaves in front of
itself and in itself an empty space it
cannot fill
this empty space is not entirely
negative
entirely unformed it is positive
attractive
of a
definable
form at least to a certain degree
sufficing perhaps to allow discernment
of what cannot enter there in a sort of
ultimatum proper for excluding
unacceptable
contributions
also faced with the normal deficiencies
of reason philosophy does not leave us
completely indifferent and ignorant it
presents itself with intellectual and
moral conditions taking account of which
is possible and required
but if one does so one sees that all the
religions are not equally acceptable nor
even innocent even if
by their speculative side far from being
a scandal for a reason far from halting
its march dog must serve as a ramp for
reasons climbing liberate it from its
falls and raise it to a more complete
and comprehensive vision
let us reassure ourselves above all
about the irreducibility of positive
religion despite all the possible
justifications and investigations
their subsistence a specific originality
a mystery that always uncovers itself
under the veils of faith
bergey
still the term catholic which you use in
preference of the term christian does it
not indicate that the philosopher
solely by rational effort comes to lay
out a certain core framework of dogmas
blondel
it is not the detail of dogmas that is
the first and principle object of
catholic philosophy it is the very
spirit in which the dogmatic teaching is
conceived and received the intellectual
core framework
of which you speak doubtless serves for
historical and critical studies from
which philosophy can benefit but the
christian truths are not the christian
spirit and none of the doctrinal
coincidences still serve so long as a
conversion of the intellect and of the
entire soul is not grasped as the
condition of the new man
that christianity must draw out from the
old man
neither the concordances between
rational assertions and revealed
teachings nor even the motives of
credibility contributing to render
belief in revelation reasonable
constitute what is essential in
adherence to catholic truth and to
catholic life the essence of the debate
bears on the motive of faith completely
different from the motives of
credibility to use a distinction whose
importance the theologians have made
precise
it is really a matter of knowing how and
why the order of grace insinuates itself
in and imposes itself on nature and
reason by perfecting them without
suppressing them and without dispensing
with them
this is a problem that neither history
nor even moral psychology ever touches
and that is nevertheless inserted into
the depths of every human thought in
every human life
a problem just as delicate to raise is
that of the supernatural insofar as it
remains unconscious but that under the
anonymous form where psychological and
rational data are its vehicles under the
very veil in which it is wrapped
engages the inevitable question of our
eternal responsibility
a problem consequently that connected in
one respect with the most personal
dispositions of the human being is at
the same time really attached to the
historical and ontological order of the
divine plan
and this is what explains how it becomes
more and more apparent that the catholic
ideal sustains in humanity the vitality
of the idea of god and of the religious
soul
even if that ideal is misunderstood or
attacked by those who still or already
take advantage of it
this is one of the reasons why i spoke
of catholic philosophy for this term has
a meaning that is at the same time
stronger more precise and more broad
christian is something like the last
name belonging to the religious family
that has if we can speak this way a
civil status in the highest history of
peoples and civilization for 19
centuries now the name catholic while it
seems restrictive is to the contrary the
universal and permanent name the human
and divine name that what implying all
that the most authentic christianity
contains of historical reality of
defined dogma and of supernatural aid
extends itself to all souls of good will
to souls who are prior to or exterior to
the preaching of the gospel but who are
really in communion with the total
assembly of minds
faithful to the light of reason of
conscience and are the most secret
graces
how much i would like that to thus
satisfy mr berger berger's so opportune
and so profound question this would be
perhaps the best way to bear witness to
him of my deep gratitude for the
generosity with which he animates this
societe de philosophie and the
intellectual hearth whose warmth he
causes to spread afar
and that is the end of part two
of the book and we're ready to jump into
part three
in further readings of this which will
include antonin sertianjes on christian
philosophy
bruno de salajas the problem of
christian philosophy
uh fairness von steinbergens the society
told me his second day of studies in the
notion of christian philosophy
and then finally
maurice blondel's foreign integral
philosophy responding to
von steinbergen and leon noel's the
notion of christian philosophy so we
have quite a bit coming up from this
this book five more sessions at least
now i will take questions and comments
and first i'm going to while other
people are writing stuff
i'm going to address
oh constanti b's stuff here
which i think
is
the questions are off to begin with and
it's not a surprise since whoever that
is
wrote them in the first minute of this
reading without listening to anything
else that was in the reading
presumably without having read you know
the passages in this book and so you
know they're they're kind of generic
and off-base questions
which
not particularly
great conversation starters but i'll
address them anyway but i do want to say
this
it's probably better to write questions
that are
a response to what we're actually
discussing in these sessions right there
is a point to this
and um you know it's easy to lose that
so
i i'm not even sure what the isn't that
uh refers to isn't that just a rehearsal
of aquinas's and other religious
metaphysics so anytime that somebody
says isn't that just
not a good way to start a conversation
not a good way to start philosophy
um
there
we want to avoid a sort of reductionism
we want to avoid a sort of dogmatism we
want to avoid a sort of shoot from the
hip kind of thing
aquinas
metaphysics is extraordinarily complex
and if you're going to expand it to
other religious metaphysics like say
that of maurice blondel who is one of
the main people in this debate
very complex as well so there's no just
about that anyway i don't know what a
rehearsal means in this case do you mean
like a repetition
or do you mean like it can't be getting
ready for it because aquinas was you
know uh hundreds of years earlier
right so
the question almost doesn't make sense
then um and i again don't know what this
is responding to since it was written
like before we even got through the
first minute of this there's a
kierkegaardian tendency here a return to
faith in moments of doubt
no
that is not what is going on here and
um
kierkegaard isn't the only person who
returns to faith in moments of doubt
but that's very oversimplifying so again
very little to work with here
when you write questions
you want to
be responding to what we're actually
talking about here
so
that is that
mark says i find the concept of grace
hard to wrap my head around but i guess
that's the point it's mysterious is
there some way to get a better grasp of
it
i would say yeah i mean one definite way
to get a better grasp of is to read
other thinkers who talk about grace you
know
it is always going to by its very nature
be something that surpasses our
intellectual capacities but that doesn't
mean that we can't wrap our head around
it to some degree both in we could say
in the abstract or generic and in
particular situations so you know for
example saint anselm is somebody who
who's quite interested in you know
making some sense out of that augustine
is somebody who's you know there's like
a whole
tradition of reflection upon
uh grace on aid that is provided
gratuitously you know grazia that's
that's what what grace
is and um you know it's in the case of
blondel it's good to keep in mind what
he's saying here which is true you know
typical
orthodox christianity
grace is not something that's like you
know like oil and water here's grace and
here's nature no they permeate each
other i mean any god that can do
something in history and you know has
some sort of you know intelligence is
not just gonna be like hammering grace
on top of you know some some sort of
recalcitrant nature
but the relations between grace and
nature in christian theology and
philosophy are quite complex so
that's that's i mean it's a really
important topic to to plumb
um
wada says as you you mentioned
coincidentally in your reading if you're
talking about grace now that's
intelligence um
yeah i'm not sure what you mean by
that's intelligence
um
do you mean that that's an intelligent
way of looking at grace or do you mean
that grace is involved with the human
intelligence it's it's a little unclear
to me there but any other
questions comments about the
stuff that we're uh
covering in here i mean by by the way if
if you do want to make sense out of
what's being said you might want to get
the book
get get your hands on a copy of the book
and that might mean uh getting your
library to to get a copy because it is
it is a bit expensive unfortunately
catholic university of america press
priced it at uh 75 bucks
rather than what i wanted which was 50
bucks
um
they're the ones who get to call the
shots instead of the press right
and um
yeah so wide it says ie super superior
intelligence and religion's deity i
still don't know what what what you mean
by that you're just sort of throwing out
like little
morsels but you're not connecting them
together
any other questions comments um like i
said
we will be uh over the next coming
months we have uh five more
chapters to get through and they're all
you know
pretty short
um well we might have to break
i don't know 16 pages uh blondels for an
integral philosophy we might have to
break that into two bits actually fernan
von steinbergen is also 16 pages but the
rest of them are pretty
short we're making some decent progress
here
mark says just to note i finally got a
hold of copies of blondel's oxyo looking
forward to reading it just got to find
the time
yeah blondel's oxygen is his uh his
dissertation or at pro freely speaking
his second dissertation because in the
french you know um uh educational
establishment at that time you had to
write
a dissertation in french and a
dissertation in latin things have gotten
considerably easier since then
and
because of writing accion and because of
the way the french academy was
structured and because of
the very anti um
uh catholic
animus in the french third republic uh
writing oxyo got him
barred basically from getting a teaching
position for
uh
two years and then he was assigned to go
teach out in the sticks rather than in
paris which he did and he was fine with
doing that
oxyo 1883 is a really great
great work
um
he will revise it later on you know he
will rethink some of the things that
he's doing there but the revisions are
always you could say expansions rather
than rejections of
original
um theses or approaches that he has
so yeah it's it's it's a good work to
get um not very often read you
definitely want the translation by
alibaba
not the translation by james somerville
i asked oliver blanchett
in emails um
why he he chose to retranslate the work
and he said that he was teaching blondel
at boston college
and he became so dissatisfied with how
crappy the somerville translation was
that he decided he needed to undertake
his own translation project and he did
that and his translation is quite good
he also has a
wonderful
roughly thousand page
intellectual biography uh which i
believe is titled maurice blondel in
intellectual life
and if you want to know more about
blondel and not just his his ideas but
his history
that is probably the book to go to um
and it came out
10 years ago i want to say
um uh
somebody's got cyrillic things can you
explain some fundamental differences
between catholic christian philosophy
and eastern orthodox one well there
isn't an eastern orthodox one and there
isn't a catholic christian philosophy
there are both are buckets that contain
many many people
um i was actually just talking about
this with a friend this morning i was
mentioning the fact that i'm i'm reading
you know augustine's confessions again
because i'm going to be teaching it and
he's he's at one time he was eastern
orthodoxy he was like oh yeah the
eastern orthodox they really don't like
augustine and i was like yeah they don't
like anselm either but almost none of
them have actually read the stuff that
they're complaining about
um and you know you can say the same
thing goes for uh you know catholics
reading eastern sources very often
doesn't happen at all but they're
they're very varied there isn't just you
know fundamental differences there
aren't really fundamental differences
there isn't a catholic take and an
take and anybody who tells you that
there is is full of [ __ ]
and uh peddling some sort of you know
theology of their own um
there's an awful lot of polemics out
there
and you want to try to avoid those you
don't want to get bought you don't want
to buy into those sorts of things
so they share way more in common than
than what they disagree upon
i mean we could talk about like you know
lavender unleavened bread who gives a
[ __ ] that's not really an important
topic although some people made it so
you know i mean a lot of these a lot of
these things that people get very very
hung up on turn out to be
quite unimportant so
all right any other
questions comments
things that people want to know
specifically about the book about
blondel
about the debates
about those sort of topics
otherwise we'll probably call it a
short session we're already 35 minutes
in we'll do another of these uh
when do i have the next one
scheduled
um maybe next week maybe the week after
that
trying to get like yeah i probably can
get one done next week i'm trying to get
like you know at least two or three done
a month
um so that we can keep making progress
in this
um
so derek says much of this is above my
understanding but i appreciate you doing
this i'm new to philosophy and i've been
enjoying your content oh great yeah this
is this is very much a meta phys
philosophical
debate right
and it has to do with the nature of
philosophy itself it is being carried
out by people at a very high level
of
development who are writing to each
other and and that's one thing that's
actually
missing in some respects except with
bruno de salaja's contribution which is
a a presentation to the general public
which we're going to get to in
two weeks or two sessions from now
and he uses metaphors to sort of clarify
these metaphors of mountain peaks that
is quite an attractive way of thinking
about it but yeah there's there's a lot
of sort of high level stuff going on
here in in these discussions and
you know
you there's there's other books as well
so i mean this is part part of the
translation of the debates
um at angel so has some works that are
translated that are germane to it like
the spirit of medieval philosophy
or philosophy and christianity uh
jacques martin has the essay on
christian philosophy that that is
translated as well and those are sort of
companion pieces
to this i should probably do some
writing about that down the line you
know like here's here's how to read
about these debates but
all right uh another from the cyrillic
writing person thank you do you think
that impact of christian philosophy of
modernist philosophical thought is
positive or negative i mean again you're
asking sort of like is the is the ocean
in the atlantic or the pacific that's
all over the place i mean
it's it's both i can say this to you
that um blondel thought that it was
extraordinarily important in our time
that christianity definitely engage
modern philosophical thought not
necessarily modernist which is a
different thing there's a variety of
ways of understanding modernist
but
that we you know we have to we have to
engage modern philosophical thought and
sift it see what's true in it what you
know replaces or surpasses the ways that
we've looked at
things in the past
um
[Music]
i mean
the other part of the question i think
that christianity had contributed
develop of individual reasoning yeah i
guess and so did plato and so did
aristotle and so did the stoics and so
did buddhism and so did we can go so did
so did so did
i i don't know that christianity has the
market cornered on that you know
and specifically christianity in modern
times um i mean that's that's kind of a
hegel take
in some ways right
but that's kind of bad history of of
ideas because we can find all these
other emphases on individual reasoning
and thought in in the past as well so
all right so i think that's probably it
i don't see any new questions i'm going
to say
see you next time we'll pick up with
antonin sertianja's
uh piece i'm a big fan of sertiano she's
a great thomist philosopher
everything's coming from this this text
and we'll see you next uh
thursday here's a
uh you know
totally irrelevant question uh what do
you think of pandemic conspiracies
related to freedom what the hell does
that have to do with this
this is a this is a session that is a
live reading
on this this work
um this is not an ama those are the sort
of questions that are good for ama which
means they ask me anything
not um just you know jump in and ask me
random stuff we're these these are kind
of focused on on you know the topics
that we're
working on here all right so i'll see
everybody later